crt
john says let them teach it because it's
a form of capitalism if some schools do
too much of it parents are going to take
their kids to a different school that's
crt now the challenge with that is if my
kids are going to public school and i
can't afford it i can't afford to take
my kids to another public school because
there's a zip code and all these other
things you're dealing with i'm a little
screwed there john if i can't afford to
take my kids to private school
no it could be public school choice
think if you were assigned to your
supermarket by your zip code
it would be
the supermarket would have no interest
in pleasing its customers
de blasio screwed new york but there's a
there are opportunities i think to
revamp the public school system no but
are you okay if they say every public
school in america is going to come and
impose a crt philosophies on the young
kids then what do you do you and i can
take our kids to private school
but the average person making 52 is
going to say dude i can't go to delaware
still crt i can't go to new york it's
still crt i can't go anywhere i don't
think you would ever see something like
that nationwide i think that the
virginia gubernatorial
election taught us that and if the
parent was if if the money were attached
to the back of the kid
and you had a system where oh that
school gets the 20 000 if i can lure
that those parents this would never
happen yeah i
regarding crt
i don't think anything should be
banned right like nothing should be
banned however i do think they're like
for instance i wouldn't want my
elementary school kid learning about crt
i wouldn't probably even want a middle
school kid but at some point 11th 12th
grade
i think it's open it up let's let's have
open conversations you're about to get
ready for the real world there's going
to be a lot tougher things you're going
to deal with than a couple than a crt
class or uh
as long as you're teaching both sides of
every story true but if you don't want
the government to just ban things you're
big fans of desantis and
i am in many ways but what about his
saying it's kind of like no one may
teach critical race theory
no one may say in this school we demand
you wear a mask
that seems totalitarian
to also not allow kids to wear masks at
certain schools
yeah not
yeah if the school chooses it and let
them do it well since
since the supreme court ruled look how
many
since the supreme court court ruled look
how many companies have abandoned their
mass mandate so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]